[Music]
so why'd you leave boston
i've been on quite the adventure little
brother
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl
he's got everything to do with that
little girl
[Music]
you know
i've never been this close
to the outside
so is that everything you hoped for
can't be any worse out there
can it
once upon a time i had somebody that i
cared about and in this world that's
good for one thing
get you killed
[Music]
i can take care of myself how many close
calls have we had
i get in trouble down there
you make every
shot count
i got this
i hope you know how to use that thing
i've had some practice
[Music]
sergeant leo alvarez of the cm left
recon squad
our mission was to enter the tantalus
base locate the comsat relay and bring
it back online
we found the relay
but there was a
problem
get that door closed now private
close again nothing gets in here
ray didn't make it
release
take the lead
oh
this ain't good
what we found was
a new kind of evil
and it found us first
what
this
wasn't human
retreat
[Music]
go go
hold that door sergeant
son of a
i don't know what i saw in there
but i know when i close my eyes
i still see it
now everyone's dead
[Music]
and someone needs to know
[Applause]
i had nothing
and then this city became my home
its people became my family
gotham gave me everything
it deserves to feel safe
oh
[Music]
no matter how hard we try
there's always more to do
and now
it's up to me
i got this bruce
signals breaking up command i'll do one
last scan see you soon over
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
command i
may be on to something
[Music]
so
[Music]
i have it command repeat i have it
mission accomplished
uh
hang tight doc i've got this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
and hell's coming with it
[Music]
this world has no hope under your watch
surrender your pain to me
and i will make you whole once more
there there my sweet child
mother won't hurt you
[Music]
parker luck
i'm gonna need some backup
[Music]
[Music]
master of puppies
my name is
counting on you again old friend
three two
one
that used to always work well it did
that one time
you will know what hit you
let me have some fun
let's get this mission started
[Music]
got you in my sights
neutralized come on
[Music]
perfect
predictable time to end this
[Music]
i'm just on another level
[Music]
eyes in the wreck all right that's our
target shadows one and two push to your
luck points let's invite ourselves in
all stations
we board clear disarm that missile be
ready for anything
this could be a draft
actual we're set
copy get to work
all shadows that miss was on this
platform
i want full containment
through
[Music]
[Music]
room clear coming out
channel one moving to the southeastern
oh
stopping doors
we're moving to the main deck what's
your status boarding the ship with
shadow three now roger
[Applause]
two copies
we got a rule
shadow one ghost visual
off
[Music]
[Music]
coming
[Music]
move to up halifax
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
clear
[Music]
roger that confirm when the objective is
neutralized
where are the controls
on that damn ship
actually we got a problem this
son is that launch
let's go let's move out
[Music]
secure those controls stop this vessel
yep how do we board
take the ramp
all night
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile controls are on the bridge
have to stop the lawn
copy that
[Music]
perfect reloading
are the only cover we have just don't
get caught between them
[Music]
towards the entrance
entry
check it controls are internal
all right stand back this is shadow one
going explosive on bridge entry
three two one execute
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta
manufacturer
1736 is heading towards your power
systems failure thanks to a bit of
heretic sabotage
so you're gonna restore the colon and
hopefully save the day
again
access the operations array and use the
cryonic rods to flush the system
preferably before something explodes
head on through the ventilation tunnels
and look for an access point
this way move it
oh
[Music]
the rods and set them where they're
needed
that's the first part done
get to the base of the matrix bar and
put those crowning rods to work
look for a way out
[Music]
bye
[Music]
yes
all right
[Music]
all right
you're alone in the realms i'm afraid
the portals are a mess
not even sure if nightingale made it
given how fragile you humans are
i'd say that staying fed dry and rested
should be your priority
if the portal arch is inactive you'll
need to make round cards from rare
resources
once you have round cards you can
activate the portal
beware though
vowel things lurk in the interromic void
waiting to get in
be ready with your axe pick
[Music]
so
[Music]
someone once said insanity runs in our
family
let it
run
[Music]
[Music]
they say it's a tale of sadness and
guilt
of an artist trapped in place beyond
redemption it's alive
this is the story of my fear
and hatred of the horror of my
loneliness and it is mine
to tell
[Music]
now i see it
all this misery
all this suffering
there was no other way
[Music]
you really
shouldn't
have
an empty shell
cannot live forever
[Music]
i was trapped in this house bound by
this body
now
i break free
[Music]
[Music]
take a look
outside did you know that they call
callisto the dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your new life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
so
welcome
to your new home
[Music]
you